مبطن من الرئيس الاوكراني فولودينير
زيلينسكي الى نظيره الفرنسي مانويل ماكوم
تهديد بمقاطعه اوكرانيا للالعاب الاولمبيه
سنه القادمه في حال مشاركه الرياضيين من
روسيا وبيلاروسيا
للالعاب الاولمبيه في باريس علينا ان
نتاكد من ان روسيا لن تتمكن من استخدامها
ولا استخدام اي حدث رياضيا دوليا اخر في
الترويج للعدوان واللي يشوفونيه الدوله
ليس باسم بلديهم بل تحت الرئه الاولمبيه
وهو قرار لا يعجب موسكو
مره اخرى على ان كل محاولتان لابعاد موسكو
عن الرياضه الدوليه ستبوء بالفشل يجب ان
يفهم ذلك كل من يدعون الدفاع عن مبادئ
اخلاقيه الرفيعه وعن فصل الرياضه عن
السياسه
عن السياسه كحجه لحضورك كاس العالم لكره
القدم الرجاليه في قطر في باريس انشاءات
الالعاب الاولمبيه مستمره والحرب في
اوكرانيا على كل اللسان عمده العاصمه
الفرنسيه تعلن دعمها لقرار اللجنه
الاولمبيه الدوليه
من المنافسات لكنني مثل بعض الوفود
الرياضيه اؤيد ان لا يكون هناك وفداني
لروسيا وبلاسيا التاريخ الحديث لروسيا مع
الالعاب الاولمبيه
بسبب قضيه منشطات وعام 2014
شتويه في روسيا كانت ثوره ميدان تهز
اوكرانيا حينها قطع رياضيون اوكرانيون
الدورات تمديدا بالعنف ضد المتظاهرين
والتدخل الروسي